I've been soldier for social justice I'm
a soldier for freedom wherever I am
actually about rights I'm about economic
rights I'm about social justice so I
view myself as a freedom fighter a
soldier for social justice I think
that's why the people to say but my
motivation is to work in this world to
create conditions where the majority of
the people of the world have better
conditions of existence when I'm in
America with them in Europe with them in
Zimbabwe would have in Africa my
motivation my drive is to make this
world a better place in particular
around basic things like freedom of
association for emphasis Embley and
freedom from poverty and economic rights
right now I'm involved in this struggle
in Zimbabwe the major problems mob way
is around true issues number one
political alleged missing what's
happening in Zimbabwe is that those who
are running our country are doing so
without the consent of the governed that
in power because the store elections
they were involved in fraudulent
elections political legitimacy is number
one challenge the second challenge is
around poor country governance which has
led to a complete failure in the
economic management of our country to
the extent that we're talking about
eighty-five percent unemployment in our
country 95% poverty levels in the
country inflation numbers official
numbers of inflation 5,000% the actual
number fifteen thousand percent life
expectance in our country thirty-five
years every week four thousand people
are dying because of hiv/aids and
malnutrition in our country if we don't
get food assistance
see a 4 million people might die of
starvation those are the challenges I'm
grappling with in my country to say why
can't we have a legitimate government
that is elected by people through a free
and fair election why can't we have
economic programs economic solutions
that will make them bubbly a globally
competitive economy and not a basket
case where we are today those are the
issues that I've grappling with at the
moment as a leader one of the leaders in
the Opposition in the map